so we're going to first start by talking
about topic modeling and what topic
modeling is and why you might want to do
topic modeling so let's all picture for
a second they're all working for a
newspaper agency and our unfortunate job
is now to organize all of both the
internal documents and the documents
which are part of the newspaper articles
so you have sports articles you have
other articles you have articles on
politics and none of this is labeled so
our idea or motivation for example here
is to try to get some structure out of
completely unlabeled textual data any
form of textual data so now one approach
to actually go about doing this is to
try and see if we can find out what
topics are inside our data set so for
example if you're looking at newspapers
if you are very neutral particles
broadly say we have three topics
politics sports and the weather
gradually boring but this is our job now
and we have to do it so one way would be
to say okay I have all these news
articles and I'm going to guess around
three topics and I'm going to fire up my
topic modeling algorithm and what I'm
going to get are a bunch of words which
represent a topic for example if I run
this on maybe 2017 newspaper articles
I'd get an article unfortunately about
American politics and Trump and so on
and so forth
I'd get one thing about weather and if
you live like me and lead it's going to
be depressing weather cold and rainy all
the time but basically depending on the
kind of articles you're dealing with
will be getting different kinds of
topics and depending on the numbers so
you can identify can try and figure out
why this might be a nice way to sort of
just put all of your documents into
different topics it's also interesting
to try and see what kind of words or
kind of ideas are in your data set so
there's a lot of motivation for using
topic models and what we're going to see
throughout the tutorial what exactly
topic models are and why it might be
useful so now that we all have an
extremely rough idea of what topic
models are that's completely enough to
actually just dive in now the second
part about the tutorials I probably
should not have actually named it a
topic modeling tutorial because there's
not too much of topic modeling there's
actually
more of text pre-processing now why does
more of text processing is when I was
first doing this tutorial and it was
only a topic modeling tutorial I
realized I was getting really really
rubbish results when I wasn't
pre-processing my text and I figured hey
this is actually more important than my
actual topic models national topic
models are one line of code with Jenson
helps me do so what we're going to do in
this tutorial is actually figure out how
to clean a data set and how to set it up
to get it ready for topic modeling but
not just for topic modeling for any kind
of texture analysis so our focus here is
more about good practices in text
analysis in general which is going to be
super helpful for actual topic modeling
you can also of course do all sorts of
text analysis with this work and so on
and so forth which genzyme also has now
what I would want everyone to do if
everyone has models downloaded in an
ideal world would be to start the
Jupiter notebook can everyone see yep so
oh yeah this is the Jupiter notebook
which I'm going to be using which
everyone should be using now there are
two things you folks can do you can
either go to my repository and find the
already run Jupiter notebook which has
every single cell of this notebook
already run so you can just follow that
notebook and look at that or you can
watch me while I press ENTER on every
single cell which cans also fun I guess
so really the only thing you are missing
out by not having the language models is
not pressing enter on the Jupiter
notebook but it could be real the reason
I spend so much time on actually
insisting on setting up the environment
is so you can go home and do what I'm
doing right now because the real fun of
text modeling is you know going trying
it on your own textual data so it's not
a huge deal if you do not have the
environment set up but it would be worth
your while to go home and actually set
it up so you can run this notebook later
so let's start so for those of you who
do have everything set up your first
step would be to get your imports done
and let's talk about what data set will
be using for this particular task it's a
terribly boring data set it's the news
data set it's well in particular is the
lead back on corpus you can
actually see you can click on the link
and go and check out the research paper
which started using the corpus as far as
we're concerned we're going to use the
data set because it's small and because
it's available in Jensen Jensen has this
is one of its default data sets and it's
super easy to get running again for
those who have the Jupiter notebooks run
but are using Python 3 please comment
out this piece of code yeah for me
because I'm using Python 2.7 because I
figured it's some people might still
need to so I may need to have these
functions this should work normally so
what we're doing over here is we're
loading our data set so text as you can
see over here
ok let's actually see what text looks
like yep so you can see that text is
yeah you can see that it's a new line
separated for each different article you
can see that more clearly after we run
the Spacey language pipeline but so far
our idea I mean until here is just to
load our textual data set so this is the
data set which should be playing with
and now and this is super important
because it's actually the bulk of our
problem I mean we're going to be solving
every single pre-processing problem with
just one a small line of code which is
over here but this is what I wanted
everyone to download which is the Spacey
English language model now I would like
to also talk about NLT Kay because it's
also a popular choice for text
pre-processing in fact most of the text
processing tutorials have seen do
they're stemming or limit izing or
whatever cleaning using NLT Kay I would
really recommend not using NLT K you can
see in this article which is linked over
here in the notebook that he talks about
Matt horrible who is the creator of
Spacey talks about how terrible NLT K is
because of how much it's
research-oriented not really fit for
industry or production level code so I
would really recommend reading this
article and really feel motivate to stop
using a no TK the article is actually
it's pretty mean
it's it sort of says why dead code
should be buried yeah so he really does
not like an Ock I'm not a big fan either
I would really recommend using Spacey
and a huge part of this tutorial is
actually motivating people to check
spacey out and to show why it's super
awesome for text processing so this one
line by the way if I'm going too fast or
if you have any questions please put
your hand up and I'll stop
but yeah so in any machine learning
problem if you're going to give rubbish
input you're going to get rubbish output
so let's really focus on cleaning our
data set here over here what we're doing
when we do NOP is equal to space it out
low DN is recruiting a language pipeline
so NOP is now our English language
pipeline now what I'm going to do right
now is I'm going to start walking you
through the process of exp processing so
in this particular case let's talk about
stop words stop words or words which we
think had add no information to our
textual analysis so in my experience and
this I actually figured out after doing
my topic modeling I ran a couple a
couple of topic models on the textual
data set the news data set which you
guys saw what you folks saw before and I
kept seeing words like say mister and
will different kinds of words which are
built on the word sin I figured that hey
say is not adding any actual information
to my stop words so what I decided to do
was add the words stay to my stop word
list now how do you decide whether a
word is a stop word spacy when you
download the English language model has
built in a lot of Word which Spacey
thinks your language are stop words
there's also a German language model so
if you are working on German language
data and you download the Spacey German
language model you'll have Spacey German
stop words and if you want to add more
words the stop word list you do it like
this now how did I figure out that you
have to do it like this Stack Overflow I
had no clue so basically what we're
doing here is my stop words is my list
of stop words I want to add to space
these list of stop words I'm going to
loop over these and for every here
lexeme is basically I'm applying my n
I'm applying my Spacey pipe line on the
word the stopper and I'm making sure
that it's a stop word by saying stop is
equal to true
so that simple if I want to add any more
words I just add more words to that list
and I have more stop words now about the
motivation of stop words again it's
because I knew that these words were
words I needed to add because I knew how
terrible my topic models were once I saw
them so really adding stop words and
knowing which words or stop words it's
really a child error game where you sort
of look at your topic models look at
words that you think are relevant to
that data set which your which are not
going to be relevant to the topic models
and figure out which words to add so are
there any problems until here yeah cool
so now in this particular cell we are
doing it's going to take a small while
and for those who are using Python 3
you're going to have to remove the clean
part because if you remember in cell
number 2 we commented it out so we would
need to doc document is equal to NLP of
text so once it's done you actually be
pretty much done with our pre-processing
the moment we've done this which is why
I really really really like Spacey
because you don't need to do step by
step when you don't even need a moment
you do you put your text through the
pipeline through Spacey's pipeline we
now have a lot of interesting
information I'm going to show you what
kind of information we have has anyone
run this particular cell yeah cool
awesome
a couple of people ok so now we're going
to see what this looks like now I think
this is the most important cell now on
book so if you let's sort of look at our
output you can see hundreds of people
have been forced to work at their home
so on and so forth that's the beginning
of the text so what's happened over here
is each word in the document so it's
sort of looping through every single
word in the document and it's assigning
certain properties to these words so for
example you'd find out if a particular
word in this document is it a stopped
word is it a number is it um is it a
word is it a noun is it a name place
animal thing you find out different
properties of each single word by
running doc so by passing your text
through Spacey's language model you're
assigning properties to every single
word
let's see how this works I'm gonna
really emphasize on the magic of Spacey
over here which you can see in this cell
where we're constructing our corpus now
a corpus here at least from Jensen's
point of view you can actually see the
link which sort of takes you through the
page or you can see what a corpus looks
like but from our point if your corpus
is a list of Lists where each individual
list inside the list is your document
and it's actually easier if I show you I
think so if I look at texts you can see
the list of Lists where every single
word is separate and broken up again so
for example we saw hundreds of people a
hundred of people have been forced to
okay they're homeless voila what we've
done after that I'm going to walk you
through every single line in cell number
eight to show you exactly what's going
on so we have to start here so we have
to tell lists texts and articles so
again a Jennsen corpus is a list of
lists where every single list inside is
your document cleaned up and separated
so what we're doing out here is for
every single word in my document if the
word is not a newline which means if
it's not the new document if it's not a
stopped word remember we don't want stop
words in our documents because top words
add no interesting information if it's
not a punctuation mark and if it's not a
number I add the lemma ties a form of
this word to my article now what is
lemma ties for mean it's basically the
root of the word for example saying said
would have say as its root word so we
don't really care about the kind of
where we only care about the context so
we only add the lemma ties form of the
word so here using space II I'm figuring
out if if it's a punctuation mark if
it's a stop word if it's a number and if
it's not any of these I'm adding just
the root to my document can you see how
easy Spacey makes our job we can also
for example say we want to add only
words you could actually make sure you
could check what kind of part of speech
that particular word is and you can have
a topic
with only words or only nouns or only
numbers so what I would like to
emphasize on over here is that makes you
understand every single line because
depending on the kind of data set you're
dealing with you're going to have to be
pre processing your text in a different
way you might want different things in
your final text model topic model and
you might not so what we're doing over
here is extremely simple we're just
checking if it's not a number if it's
not a stop word and I'm making sure to
add the lemma ties form to my final
corpus let's take some time here to try
and figure out what's going on are there
any questions there's anyone slightly
confused here yes it no the part of
speech a noun or verb and so on and so
forth you could also find out if it's it
does NER which is named entity
recognition for example your language
model is trained to know if it's a place
a location a geopolitical a work of art
so for example if I would actually talk
about this here um okay it's actually in
the end of my this thing I basically
talk about what else Pacey has to offer
apart from text reprocessing so in our
particular case space is really useful
for the job because once we do a doc is
equal to NLP of text we're doing
basically all our text is being
processed by P spaces pipeline the only
information which we are using from this
is whether if it's a stop word or if
it's a number pretty basic things but
you can get really funky with this and
use of all the properties of spaces like
seem to try and figure out what kind of
data set you want to build so well we
won't be talking so and also we have
lots of different language there's also
the French German English and I think
they have things like Hungarian in alpha
mode and alpha so you can like whatever
a lot of language support over there you
can actually check spit I would really
recommend checking spacey out and seeing
all the cool things that can offer in
our case we're only going to use it to
clean our data set which is again in
this particular cell you can see exactly
what's going on if it's not a newline
and so on and so forth but you can
really go crazy with this I'm going to
leave
this census has nothing to do with topic
modeling I won't go into it but this
just shows some of the power which space
he has that's an unsure question oh and
by the way the question yeah yeah yeah
it's super cool it's so it's chained
using a neural network and before they
use more traditional linguistic rules to
figure this out now it's all done on
your networks of course accuracy it's
not going to be perfect every single
time but you can keep training it and
making it better and like since the
shoes modeling thing is the fact that
they have language models in many
languages French German and I think
Spanish is being worked on think someone
was doing Norwegian so you can yeah
check spacy out it's totally cool and as
for creating our corpus this is what
we're doing you can act I would
recommend seeing text let's look at just
your first document so you can see how
it's been cleaned up from hundreds of
people have been forced to okay their
homes we have hundreds of people for
silicate home you can see what we're
doing out here is only keeping key
information from the original text and
this is extremely important in text
processing because I don't need words
like offs and uh - they're not gonna add
any information to my topic model so by
using space C and on an otk we have
super fast text modeling and you can
also use spaces other things I've linked
to different notebooks and different
projects you can use only using Spacey
at the end of this digital notebook so
totally check spacey out which is why I
was insisting on getting a language
model downloaded over here but even if
it's not you know what kind of problems
to experience abound doweling language
small you can go home and do it I would
really recommend that are there any
questions about why a jensen corpus
looks the way it does or what if you
understood what a jensen corp is
supposed to look like and also what
space is doing yeah
yep so it's a good question the question
is why did it all say so all the
different kinds of words which stem from
say and not just say this is because the
stop words does not look at the lemon
ties form the stop words look at the
original word so what I could have done
I could have done W dot lemma is stopped
as well but I just decided to add all
the different kinds to give more of an
example of how stopping words stop water
but I hope your questions answers I
could have done that too yeah
is there anything else we can really
spend lots of time over here because
after this it becomes rather trivial are
just going to be using Jensen's topic
models to find your topic models this is
really the most important part of it
like cell number eight is what you
really need to understand and appreciate
because in a few lines of code we're
really creating a corpus which is really
cool and the best part is you can use
this for Jensen for scikit-learn
for whatever kind of text processing
machine learning algorithm you have in
mind yeah oh yes it does so you can you
can do that yeah again so this is since
this is not relevant to generating our
topic models I'm not going to get into
it but there's actually uh there's like
for example they've done something
called I think LD a two-cent so they
actually use sentiment analysis and lda
and the analyze read it and there's a
lot of cool projects on the spacey page
please you're not paying me by the way I
just really like Spacey
but yeah you should you can do that you
can find out sentence structure trees
and a lot of cool things so again just
to emphasize we're by running a Spacey's
language model on our text file we're
also learning about things like nouns
and parts of speech but we're not using
them the only part which are using is
stop words and numbers so it's still
extremely useful and also limit izing so
it's so extremely useful for us but
we're only really touching the surface
here with Spacey's power so as anyone is
this part clear have you understood what
a jensen corpus is and why it looks like
that yeah
cool awesome
yep so like I've just been saying the
whole time we're only using this much
now we're going to use our first Jensen
the first bit of Jensen which is
actually something called by Grahams so
again by Graham's or something which I
figured I should be using after I got
really rubbish results in my first topic
model the same way figure out with stop
words use so what by Graham's is we're
going to be in for example when some
words tend to appear around each other
more commonly like New York makes more
sense as New York rather than new and
York so we decide to combine them I've
sort of given the motivating example
over here and if any of you are
following my Jupiter notebook which is
already run you can actually go down to
the first topic model and you can find
words like Bin Ladin instead of bin and
latinus two separate words so you can
understand the motivation of why you
would need to use a diagram it's because
sometimes the word Bin Ladin makes more
sense to me than Bin Ladin in New York
makes more sense to me then another
important thing out here is our model
our textual data set which we're using
is actually of the Australian
Broadcasting data set so New York is not
a word which is going to come up so if
the word New York will existed in one
particular sentence in this data set it
would actually not be found because what
by grounds do is for that particular
data sets you'll find things like New
South Wales and Bin Ladin because these
were diagrams which are brought up quite
often in that data set but not other
ones so you can actually see what goes
on by over here though I'm not sure if
you can see it immediately but oh yeah
can you see New South over here and if
you look at text over here it was new
and south to the Fords so we're creating
diagrams super easy and it's yep why did
I use by graham's is because again like
I said I looked at my topic model and I
found out I was getting more information
when I use diagrams you could so it's
really something which you sort of
figured out you might or might not need
but I think it's an important concept to
know when you're working with an Okie in
general is that clear yeah
all right here Oh actually so over here
in phrases we shall first ensure love
would you happen to know if it does a
default if they pick up by grants or
does it
yep Sorokin the question was whether I'm
supposed to repeating questions oops the
question was about whether I had to
specify it was by grams of trigrams no
the default is by grams like let's sort
of view so is that part clear can we
move on yeah yeah I'm sorry could you be
though it's just the most probable by
grams so for example I know what else
for a couple hundred people has not come
across so many times so it wouldn't pick
up hundred people but it's seeing New
South Wales a bunch of times so it's
yeah like for example if I was running
it on the Harry Potter books then I
might find hi Potter but not Ron Weasley
because no one really says Ron Weasley
they just see Ron so uh okay umm Salama
13 is also quite important because what
we're going to be doing is we're going
to be converting our well we're going to
be converting what our data set looked
like over here which is texts we're
going to be converting that into a bag
of words format does anyone here so I'm
bag of words is a representation where
we count the number of occurrences of
each word in that particular document so
I'm going to show you what exactly it
looks like
so basically what this means is that
again it's just a list of lists but here
document number one says that word ID
number zero occurs one time in this
particular document so what we're doing
is we're basically mapping every single
word to an ID and then we're making a
bag of words out of it is that clear or
just do I need to explain this yeah oh
cool
okay so we're pretty much done with what
I think is important part of this which
is creating a clean dataset which we can
actually work on this is sort of the key
takeaway and right now we're going to
sort of be talking about what topic
models are and how we're going to use
this corpus which we created yeah
so question I'm sorry is gonna repeat
the question the question was about if
you what's going to happen if you want
try again this one and so forth and the
answer is if you run the by exam again
it's going to create trigrams and so on
and so forth yeah can we use what would
you the question is can we use it for
semantic modeling but I'm not sure what
it is
what did we create apart from the corpus
we just created a an easy way for us to
do our text analysis we created a corpus
well it depends on what kind of input
your semantic modeling algorithm accepts
but if it accepts a bag of words format
then of definitelya so the main idea
here again is sort of to introduce
everyone to what Spacey can do and how
to include Spacey in your natural
language processing pipeline so now that
we're done about Spacey um it's actually
moved to topic modeling now I briefly
talked about what topic modeling was and
why we might need to use topic modeling
before we start off so let's see what's
going on and one of my favorite parts
about topic modeling in general or in
this particular case about Jensen is how
easy and how you don't need to worry
about any mathematics or any of the it's
a black box and you can use it really
easily for example out here it's absurd
what all you just need to tell the
number of topics and pass a dictionary
and corpus and if you don't have a
corpus and dictionary then you're not
doing any text modeling so literally the
only thing which we needed to tell
Jensen here is the number of topics
that's it so they'll run the algorithm
which we are going to be using is LSI or
latent semantic indexing yeah
so the question is about by grams why
did it not pick up South Wales and only
picked up new South so all my intuition
is an unlock Letitia but in the data
said I think that new and South could
have been something else as well or no
okay that's probably the right answer
yes I'm sorry I've not actually worked
on the phrases part of the modules so
I'm really not sure that would be much
better at answering these questions oh
yeah yeah so it'll be faster yeah okay
so um yeah so we're doing over here on
line number 16 is very running our first
topic model on the corpus with ten
topics now we're going to look at top
five topics over here and yeah and all
of you who are running a super inner
book yourself might be getting slightly
different topics that's completely
normal so yeah so we can see exactly
what a topic model looks like I
previously talked about how each topic
model is a collection of words so you
can see over here that topic 0 is about
the israeli-palestinian conflict and so
stop it - but topic 4 which is ID number
3 is little more interesting or less
interesting depending on it's about a
firefighter's and yep so you can see we
only use ten topics over here but this
is what a topic model looks like yeah
that's also because the minus and plus
well I move on to HTTP and Lda which is
I think more so over here the numbers
can be deceiving because if only the
modulus counts it's so this is just to
give you an idea what a topic model
looks like basically we can interpret
each topic as a distribution of words
and we can think of each document as a
distribution of topics so this means
that topic zero has the following words
and each document would be made of a
distribution of topics so if document
number 73
we had 45 percent topic zero and 20
percent topic 1 and maybe the remaining
25% in topic 3 you can understand what
each document is made of so a document
is no longer just a bunch of words put
together it's a bunch of topics this
yeah so I actually get asked this
question at every single time I do this
true and everything so I always google
it and actually it does not matter is a
I'm going to need left to again confirm
on an analysis list on yeah so in this
particular I'd ask you to actually just
ignore that and but so but in Lda in
HTTP I'm yeah I'm sorry
so this is just a given exact like
normally I put LSI over first because I
don't like to talk about what it is and
also because I just want to give an
example of what a topic model is
supposed to look like when we move on to
Ald HTTP which is right below this so I
can actually explain you're going to
figure it out but yes well that's
actually because of the number of that's
actually showed the show topics method
over there
I put of 10 because if I do 20 or 30 or
even longer it's going to stop making as
much sense because then all of them are
going to look like the most probable
words in each topic I can hold on well
to answer a question basically each word
in your vocabulary has a number
associated with it we only look at the
highest values or the most relevant ones
you can see there's a lot clearer in the
HTTP model where unlike the LSI you can
actually interpret the topics for
example you can see here in topic 0 that
it's 0.007 Israeli which means that
topic 0 has a that percentage of chance
of having is really being represented by
the topic I'm sorry oh yeah
so here this would make a lot more sense
you can actually see oh yeah so this
means topic 0 has that topic
distribution of words and topic 1 has
additional words and so on and so forth
and you can also see there are more
words so you you asked why I only have
the top 10 words it's because I chose
the top 10 words the default number of
words I'd like to see you can see the
top 20 top 30 but they're not going to
make as much sense because every topic
is going to start looking like each
other after that yeah yes
oh yes you would because it's randomized
we're not gonna be getting the exact if
we fix a random feed then we'll get the
exact same topic distribution but
because we're all running different
random seeds our topics you're gonna
look slightly different there yeah so we
are yeah of course
definitely so I would so I would call it
a my Israeli topic but it could also be
topic I would rather call the proper way
to color to be topic ID number zero and
topic ID one and topic ID two and so on
and so forth so well there are a bunch
of ways you can do it one were to
actually look at the topic but I'm also
going to be talking about a really handy
kit called PI LD a wish which sort of
allows you to visualize these topic
models so you can interpret the topics
in a cooler way but the way I would do
it is this actually go through it so
it's manual would actually have to go
through the topic and figure out what
you'd want to call it because for
example you can choose to interpret a
combination of words different people
can interpret a combination words in a
different way so it's just what I would
call the Israeli topic and the
firefighter topic and there's one about
Hare Krishna and gain jizz and stuff
like sure it's gone over there but yeah
so each topic can be interpreted by the
person in different way ya know so what
happens is you would also notice that
for example of Australia is in a bunch
of topics yeah what it means is that
topic 3 or topic ID number 3 has
extremely high probability of having the
word Australia in it another topics
would not so every single topic has
every single word with different
probabilities so the reason I would not
do top hundred words would be because
it's highly likely the last 90 words
have no end no relevance to the topic
you can you can think of it like that
yes so is it clear what exactly a topic
model is because this is this is a topic
model so please we can take some time
here to answer questions
so that's a good question so each topic
model performs frankly differently and
we'll also be briefly talking about how
to compare between different topic
models at the end of this notebook but
yes each topic model is slightly
different and each it might not be the
top leg model for you so each topic
model again depends really on the person
and for the task at hand and why you
want to use it so we'll be talking about
comparing models at the end of this yes
yes yes there's also going to be a talk
tomorrow complete only about comparing
topic models yet but the after thing
3:00 p.m. or something so please that
would be a really nice way to make sure
you actually understood what's going on
here yeah anything else cool so we're
gonna now so the HDP is the record
rhetoric process this is super awesome
if you notice we only put the corpus in
the dictionary we could not be lazier we
did not it's almost requires no
parameters and it's really neat now
let's look at Lda so you're going to see
that these topic models behave in pretty
much the same way in sense of what the
output is it's just the conceit
considering this like we're treating
them like black boxes at the moment we
don't really need to know what it's
doing but apart from the fact that we
need to realize why the result looks
like the way it does so you can actually
if you're running this on your own
machines you can actually look at your
LD a topic model your HTP topic model
and see how it's different and the
quirks and play around with it
any questions you'll also be probably
getting slightly different topic models
compared to the ones I have so now we're
going to we had a question about how you
can interpret these topics or pile us is
one of my favorite ways to do this so
for those who manage together everything
set up you should be able to see
something like this just pretty neat
so you can actually see if you can
actually see each topic and it's quick
afford sometimes only do you spend some
time to explore this click on your mouse
you have to set up okay so you can also
see how much of the topics overlap like
over here these words you talk about
some words being in multiple topic
models for example what I once did a
really really bad topic analysis on the
Harry Potter data set I had all the
books and every single topic was just
Harry Hermione Ron went over and over
again ten topics so that was this all
stacked on top of each other and was
absolutely terrible so this is actually
a really neat way to figure out if a
topic model works or not
so after looking at this I went back and
added stop words and buy grams and so on
and so forth but yeah well that depends
on yeah it mean this less of an overlap
that's what I would like here but
sometimes it makes sense for certain
topics to be similar
it means that they have the same words
yeah
this is for topic 0 LG model is right I
thought isn't it
yeah so we can out we can move on to we
can talk about pile daters right after
this we're going to start running up so
I just want to sort of round up what
we've discussed so far oh yeah I'm sorry
are you looking at pile Davis again oh
that's yeah so we're doing like I was
mentioning since we're doing a PC age of
break break it up it's access one and
two it should be wood
yep so my answer lives answers I'm not
really sure because pile deal is is uh
not something I worked on before but the
way I use it is as a tool to find out if
my topic model is rubbish or not I don't
actually use for example there's a they
talk about salience II and relevance
over here in the bottom over here and
these are actually two currents have not
actually come across anywhere else on
which I really don't know anything about
so I'm not sure the internal workings of
pile da with it's a third party to which
I just used to visualize my topic model
so unfortunately I cannot answer your
question sorry so you can actually use
you can use different topic models in
pile do is uh you can have also there's
some tutorial notebooks which I've
written which allow you to use like your
old topic model and you can sort of
break up so basically you need to pass
matrices which are documented words and
topic word matrices and which allow you
to visualize it what Jen simple pile
they will this does is when you pass an
Lda model it does everything under the
hood so if you're interested in
visualizing other kinds of topic models
then I'll be you can use the link at the
end of this tutorial to do that so we
only have one part after this which is
topical parents so because we're the end
of our tutorial I just want to talk
about everything we discussed today the
main takeaway is really just Spacey and
how to pre-process your text because
like I said topic modeling is something
which you can really easily do topic
modeling is just importing Jen sim and
running your topic model of choice and
then depending on your use case figuring
it out what I wanted to use was topic
modeling as a motivating example of why
you need to properly pre-process your
text and why you should probably be
using Spacey to do so it's because you
can use not you can after you finish
using the spacy pipeline to clean your
text you can also go on to your space
sea for using other things like someone
talked about your language your roots of
your sentences and how you can visualize
them they have tools for visualizing
your sentence routes you can now apply
you can build neural networks into
sentiment analysis using Spacey
so there's a lot of alternate uses for
Spacey apart from using it for Jensen
for topic modeling but in general it's
really important to know how to clean
your data set depending on what you want
to do after it
the
topic models I got before au Spacely
were quite terrible and it's really
important to clean your data set before
you go on to analyze it so whether using
topic models or work to a core whatever
you want to do just make sure that
you're being really careful and each
data set is going to look different the
one which we used over here is actually
quite simple to clean up for example I
work with things like facebook messenger
tax texts and whatsapp tax wishing it
really chaotic in which case space is
really good for cleaning things up and
you can also use NLT k if you want to
but the real focus here is yes Spacey
and I've added links all over the
tutorial about other things which you
can use using Spacey and Jensen as well
so yeah please actually go back and make
sure you have your language model set up
and actually check these links out and
use their own fun data sets and play
around with it you'll get really cool
results and before I say before I finish
up we're going to talk about deciding
which topic model is better I had a
question about someone mentioning how
HTTP look better than LSI now we can
actually see if it is so topic currents
was sorry so you can see the next few
couple of cells over here we're going to
run the last four selves and what we're
going to be doing is get a coherence
value no the whole idea of this is again
some people talk about how you decide
whether a topic is a good topic or not
just by looking at a bunch of words
because each person interprets the topic
differently topic Arends is a way for us
to find out which topic is better from a
human readability point of view this was
implemented last summer with the umass
and different kinds of we have basically
have new kinds of topic events models
set up right now so you can actually get
numbers now you don't have to think
anymore and we can get a 0.56 which is
greater than 0.5 0 and we know that
topic model works better so some
important points remember is this number
is only for that particular data set you
cannot compare top top occurrence values
on LD on topic
or estranged on different data sets so
you would need a topic model B to be
trained on the same data set before you
actually use any currents on it if you
can see what you're done over here is we
create our topics for LSI for HTTP and
Lda we then create a current model and
we passed we got our current values and
just that we can plot this someone said
HDPE was better than either side oh yeah
you're hunters right according to the
topic Lawrence measure which is being
used HTTP gives you the best value again
these are just numbers and you should
take it a pinch of salt your topic you
might be absolutely convinced that your
Lda topic model is better that could be
correct top occurrence is actually just
one way to compare topic models from a
quantitative point of view you're
actually going to find out a lot more
about comparing topic models tomorrow
there's a talk on just about comparing
topic models so you're probably going to
get more into the mathematical theory of
topic models in general tomorrow
but for how to actually create a topic
model well yeah so I saw a hand up yeah
okay so I don't actually know the
complete I just know the intuition the
intuition I think is human readability
which is what they talked about in the
research paper I'm not sure about the
mathematical details I don't know if
love might know the exact
so the question was what is the
mathematical basis what is the intuition
behind it and as love explained I'm
going to be quite brief today basically
uh they do use a grid search to find out
which was a better way to figure out
which is the most human readable topic
so I would have not read the research
paper myself so I'm just yeah you should
read the paper really interested in the
mathematical basis but the intuition is
what's the most human readable topic
I don't use topic currents too much it's
usually nice to just sort of have a
rough idea but normally you sort of look
at the topics and use PI LD a ways to
get an intuition again I use PI L do is
just to visualize what my topics look
like I don't really read into the
mathematical part behind it which I
probably should but oh yeah so now you
know how to clean your extremely dirty
datasets and how to get it ready for
whatever text analysis you want to do
I'd like to thank Lev who was my google
Summer of Code mentor last year for help
for being here and helping me out
especially with the Matt bits not so
good at that and if you have any
questions I'm here around tomorrow and
day after as well I love to talk about
topic models and text analysis I hope
we're all going to use Spacey and
install the language models I'm sorry
about that in the first half an hour it
wasn't as smooth as I would have wanted
but I hope everyone got something from
this and well thank you for coming
[Applause]